dr hari valpola
is a computer scientist and entrepreneur
with huge ambition four years ago
he started his company curious ai in
helsinki
because he wanted to realize his dream
of the next
level of artificial intelligence going
from system
one to system two it's a lofty ambition
and what does that entail in the 1960s
many researchers thought that in just 10
years time
it would be possible to build computers
that are as good as humans in every
cognitive task
now 50 years later it's easy to say that
well
that didn't happen my goal is to build
human-like ai that my mother would be
happy to work with
i started with asking can we build
this human-like a.i yes we can
hari is an expert in machine learning
theoretical neuroscience
and cognitive robotics he's been an ai
researcher for 25 years
having led multiple research groups and
his work has been published multiple
times
in the top machine learning conference
eurips
he has even published work with yan
lacoon in 2012.
curious ai specialise in industrial and
business process
optimization they've developed some
extremely sophisticated approaches
around unsupervised learning and model
based reinforcement learning
i hope many of you have read daniel
kahneman's
great book thinking fast and slow we
were having a wonderful discussion about
system one versus system two last week
when we dissected yoshia benzio's iclr
keynote presentation
hari believes that model-based
reinforcement learning approaches
are system two because of the
imagination
curiosity and planning that goes on
inside these models system one
is the autopilot it's the
it's the part of my brain that's doing
biking for instance
it's very fast it's intuitive i don't
need to think about it
in fact i cannot think about it i cannot
explain how i do it
i just do it it's unconscious fully
automatic
and crystallized knowledge
it's something that i learn from
experience from a lot of data
sounds family right very much like
artificial
intelligence these days what we have now
in ai is this system one
what we are missing is this creative
system too which is able to handle new
situations
my brain is able to imagine things
i have simulations going on inside my
brain
and that's the foundation of this system
too
this is what we need to build without
that
we would be like reflex machines
and reflex machines is how deep learning
looks like so
system two it relies on internal models
planning and then selection over
different possible future outcomes it's
slow because you have to
simulate the world and then select the
best outcomes you may have heard about
the alpha goal
alphago is an example of a
ai system that relies on planning
so it has system two it's not
general artificial intelligence because
the model that it's using is hand coded
it knows the rules of the game they have
been handcrafted there
but having this ability to plan forward
it's able to start to learn the game of
golf from scratch it doesn't know
how to make good moves it doesn't know
how good a particular board situation is
when it starts
but it does know the rules of the game
so it starts playing
against itself in its head it's thinking
thinking thinking millions and millions
of games
it's thinking about the game and it's
developing this expertise
how do you make a business out of ai i
think too many of us are familiar
with the situation where you're starting
on a real world project and the best
solution
is just a linear regression or a k
nearest neighbor classifier
here is someone that makes
state-of-the-art machine learning
into a company and actually makes money
out of that
one configuration of reinforcement
learning is that you code an expert
system simulator
from first principles and learn your
policy from that
the policy is the model in reinforcement
learning
that predicts which action to take based
on the current situation
you can even use the simulator for
planning ahead from your current
situation
without needing to take action in the
real world and this has been
successfully used in robotics
and gaming but what if you don't have
the luxury of knowing how to write your
environment simulator
using code sometimes writing even an
approximate simulator
for a well-known system is extremely
expensive
aligning your simulator to your actual
process can be challenging
and also the environment is often
non-stationary
in this situation we create a world
model
using machine learning to simulate our
environment instead
one of the benefits of using your
imagination so to speak
is that you get orders of magnitude
better sample efficiency
which is one of the biggest problems
dogging reinforcement learning
in model based reinforcement learning
planning is done by computing the
expected result of a sequence of future
actions
given this learned model of the
environment this is not without
challenges though
out of distribution generalization
errors and optimization
failures due to adversarial examples and
model overfitting
are common challenges with model-based
deep reinforcement learning
the folks at curious ai have come up
with some extremely interesting
solutions to
this for example using denoising auto
encoders
and also working on some new approaches
for planning and exploration in
model-based reinforcement learning
we want to model the transitions in the
environment a powerful world model can
accurately predict
the next state given a state action pair
in a recent study gamegan
researchers from nvidia showed that they
could emulate pacman
inside of a world model this world model
can model the state action next day
transitions
in the pixel space another paper world
models from david haw
and jurgen schmidt huber show a similar
success modeling viz doom with a
variational auto encoder in pixel space
many other techniques don't bother
modeling the high dimensional pixel
space
models such as mu0 and dreamer learn
transitions in a compressed
latent space saving computational
efficiency and still achieving the
sample efficiency of model-based
reinforcement learning
the ability to predict the future in
these world models enables
agents to utilize planning to take
better actions
planning algorithms such as the monte
carlo tree search used in alphago
look ahead several steps to get a better
sense of the immediate action
in regularizing trajectory optimization
with denoising auto encoders
valpola and his collaborators describe
planning as an adversarial attack
against the agent's own forward model
where these planning algorithms exploit
errors in the future predictions
to propose trajectories that don't work
in the real world in the paper they
present a technique
using denoising auto encoders to deal
with this uncertainty
usually we think of model-based
reinforcement learning for vision and
modeling sequences of rgb frames
but curious ai is on the cutting edge of
using these techniques to model
industrial control processes
such as paper mills or sewage systems
i'm really looking forward to learning
more
about the challenges of model-based
reinforcement learning with this kind of
data and harry's perspective on this
direction of reinforcing learning
in the most recent eurips the number one
machine learning conference
curious ai published a paper called
regularizing trajectory optimization
with denoising auto encoders yannick was
really interested in this and he made a
comprehensive
video on his own youtube channel i just
want to include 10 minutes of that video
here
to give you guys a flavor of the kind of
innovative technology that curious ai
are developing
model based reinforcement learning means
that you are using a model of the world
to do
reinforcement learning so in essence
if you have your reinforcement learning
setup where you are an
agent and you have to interact with the
world
you have to do so in many steps in like
a round-trip fashion so you
put in action you act and the world
gives you back
an observation and you have to act in
the world
over and over and over such that you
will be
able to maximize your reward now what is
model-based reinforcement learning
basically means that the
agent here has internally
a model of the world so it sort of
understands
how the world works situations where you
have a
accurate model of the world are things
like chess so in chess
the rules are very clear you know how
the world's going to behave
if you perform a certain action but in
real world applications it's very very
hard to actually
make a model so people usually rely on
learned models
so what does it mean you basically learn
a neural network that tries to
predict how the world is going to act so
this here is going to be a deep neural
network
that you learn from what you see in the
world
now trajectory optimization basically
means
that you now have this world model and
you
use it to look ahead so you are in the
state like here and you can do
let's say three different actions and
you use your world model here
world and you see you think how's the
world going to react if i do either of
those three things
and then you get into three different
states and then again you after each one
you consider
three actions three actions here three
actions here
and so on so ultimately you're going to
kind of have an overview over our
planning horizon
which here we call h you kind of look
ahead a couple of steps
or there are various ways of doing this
but ultimately you will basically
find that ah this this path here is
really good
so i think i'm going to take this as a
first action
so trajectory optimization considers
finding the best
green path here in this tree of
possibilities
that your your world model gives you
what do these people say
they say this procedure often suffers
from exploiting inaccuracies of the
learned model
what does that mean that basically means
that if i have a world model
and it is not accurate then it is
basically
the the thing that tries to find the
best screen path here the optimizer
is trying to find the the best path
against
this world model now if that world model
is inaccurate
that can lead to devastating
consequences so what do we mean by this
i'll give you an example if you have a
room right and the room is
let's take our classic room like this
and you are here and you would like to
go
here right and so you're a reinforcement
learning agent did you do some
exploration right you explore a bit
here the next episode you might go here
and you might go here and so on
and over time in this framework you're
going to build
a model of the world so at the beginning
we won't tell you
how these rooms look you have to
discover it by yourself
so maybe at the beginning we only tell
you uh there's these four walls the rest
you have to figure out
so on and on you're gonna fill in your
blanks you do your first explorations
and you say
there's a bit of a wall here right and
uh there might be some wall here i
crashed into that right you're going to
here
you crash into a wall you saw there's a
wall here and here ah there's a wall
here you go maybe here
oh there's no wall so you go further
there's no wall anywhere here you crash
here okay we already knew there's a wall
maybe you crash here
all right so right now you have okay you
go here
you have you have a model of the world
in this situation
where there's a wall here a wall down
and if you now try to do trajectory
optimization
remember you have to go from here to
here if you try to do trajectory
optimization
what is it going to turn out it's going
to turn out like look
there you go that works just fine
and that's not because you're so good at
planning i mean you are good at planning
but because
your model is inaccurate here because it
has never seen this your entire training
distribution
that you trained the world model on only
explored
the area over here right so you see how
the more efficient this planning
algorithm is
like the blue arrow the thing that finds
the blue arrow
the more efficient that is the more
consequential it is
when your learned world model has
mistakes
because it will exploit these mistakes
in order
to get the shortest path possible or the
highest reward in that case
they call this like almost an
adversarial attack on the world model
which is a pretty good way of framing it
they propose to solve this problem they
say we propose to regularize trajectory
optimization by means of a denoising
auto encoder
that is trained on the same trajectories
as the model of the environment
we show that the proposed regularization
leads to improved planning with both
gradient based
and gradient free optimizers important
to note here
is that the world model will only learn
about
things that you have done right
so there is kind of an interaction
effect that's the green area
here the world model only knows the
paths the world model only can
accurately estimate the world where you
have been
and that's going to turn out to be the
entire problem because
this blue arrow finder can now go away
from
the potential inaccuracies of the
trained model
cause substantial difficulties for the
planning process
rather than optimizing what really
happens planning can easily
end up exploiting the weaknesses of the
predictive model
planning is effectively an adversarial
attack against the agent's
own forward model this results in a wide
gap between expectations based on the
model
and what actually happens okay
and they have this this example here
where it's like an industrial control
process and what you have to imagine
there's like some sort of a
container here with a liquid in it and
there are two two pipes that lead to
this container
pipe one and pipe two and there are
valves here
so there's this valve right here and
there's this
valve right here so these are valve one
and valve two
and there is also an output pipe right
here and that's
a another valve right here so you can
control these three
valves the in two inputs and one output
and you have to somehow
optimize the reaction in here so this is
a chemical reaction
made up out of the two liquids that flow
in here and you have to somehow optimize
a property of that and that's highly
non-linear and has maybe like time time
shift so
when you open a valve it's going to take
a while and then it's
very non-linear and then you are not
supposed to break the pressure limit so
you have to also
outflow some stuff and if you just
do this with a learned model it looks
like this so first of all
here is a classic controller like people
have been doing this stuff in industry
and they basically build controllers for
it
and you can you can do that and that
works out really
okayish as you can see right here
this is the product rate what you're
supposed to optimize and you see some
sort of a
smooth you're supposed to actually bring
it to this dashed line right here
and this is some sort of smooth thing
right
and you're supposed to i guess bring the
pressure here and
the a in purge i don't know what these
quantities are but you're supposed to
bring them
to the dashed line and it's very
non-linear
and very time dependent so that works
and you see here kind of the smoothness
by which the variables are manipulated
now if you just learn a world model and
then do this
trajectory optimization you see right
here
it works but it's super jittery
the pressure spikes here and apparently
this here is a pressure limit so it
spikes the pressure limit
and you can see that the manipulated
variables are up and down and up and
down and up and down because
at each step it basically completely
overestimates
its potentially rewarded things like wow
this is really good
but all it does is find a weakness in
the model and not a really good
action per se now with their method
to already take it away you can see
that now the control task super smoothly
and very quickly converges
to these optimal things and you can see
that the
variables being manipulated are also
rather smoothly manipulated
and that's an indication that the model
is
accurately estimating their rewards
if we go back to our rooms example right
you you see that
anywhere in the green area where i have
already explored
the world model is fairly good right
it's going to give me
accurate reflection of the world but as
soon as i go
outside the green area it is not
and inside the green area is basically
where my training data is
now if i in the future actually take a
path here
crash into a wall right here right you
saw in the algorithm
at the end of an episode i'm going to
add my trajectory to
the training data for the world model so
this green part here expands to include
that and now if i go here again
if my plan goes there again now i can
trust the world model but also now it
has
it is actually correct because it has a
wall here so you see
that the regularization basically you
not only do i want
the biggest reward possible under my
world model i also want
that the plan that i'm about to execute
is has a high probability under my
training distribution
okay and the way we do this is by
denoising
auto encoders now when i go and do my
trajectory optimization
and my trajectory optimization wants to
go here i simply say
no i don't know that i haven't seen that
yet you can only
plan basically within the space where
we have already been so you can plan
like here so here now there is of course
there is going to be
some exploration so some probability
that
you can go away a bit but not too much
right so in this case it would result
in the planning only to happen in spaces
where we've actually been so it might
go here and then here because okay
here we haven't been anywhere but then
that would lead me
to take the first step in this direction
and not in this direction
and if i take my first step in this
first direction
then of course i'm going to be already a
bit
on the correct path right here whereas
if i take the first step into this
direction
then after that i'm going to have to if
once i crash here i'm going to have to
correct really hard
and that's exactly what's going to give
you this
super jittery control it is incredibly
fascinating to
listen to hari and i had a lot of fun
talking to him
and i hope there's a nugget of advice
for everyone
in there i think that was a great
opportunity for yannick to show some
context
and demonstrate the exciting technology
that curious oh i are working on
we had a fantastic conversation with
hari and we really appreciate that he
came on the show to talk with us
so without further delay i give you hari
valpola
welcome back folks to the machine
learning street talk channel with me
my two compadres yannick kilcher connie
shorten
and today we are incredibly excited
about this we've got a guest on
hari who started a reinforcement
learning company in in europe and we've
been talking a lot about system one
versus system two
and hari's company is all about
embracing this next paradigm of
computation there's this system two
and last week hari we actually used your
analogy of
the the monkey which was when when these
cards were handed out
and humans could spot the hidden rule
very quickly they had to classify these
cards into one or two classes
and monkeys don't spot the hidden rules
so
there was an assertion there that humans
have this higher level of thinking this
so-called system two
can can you give me the elevator pitch
hari yeah
thanks tim so elevate a pitch about
monkeys
and system two or elevate a pitch about
what curious ai is doing about
building ai that actually has system two
well i i think the first thing is a
wonderful segue into the second thing
okay so there's this interesting
experiment where where you train
or give give uh monkeys or
humans recognition or classification
task
which the test subject doesn't know
about
in advance so it's really a test about
how quickly
you can extract some some rules and
you know recognition system and
monkeys and humans oftentimes
also when when they pick up the first
card and then they
will see some kind of funny image and
then they will need to make
a decision is this a or b they will
start
making their guesses and then gradually
by
getting feedback they they learn
and they they improve their performance
gradually
but sometimes humans
figure out the rule like they they can
explicitly tell
oh okay i understand so the rule seems
to be
that if you have a black and white
picture then it's class a
and if it's colored picture then it's
class b
when they are able to explicitly
fill out the rule their performance
immediately jumps to 100
so this is very typical of system two
thinking as long as it's this big data
ai system one ai or system one learning
it's it's going to be gradual and slow
it's an instantaneous intuitive response
we just know okay this
this card looks like a you can't say why
but that's that's how it looks like
but the moment you spot the rule once
you
understand it in deeper level you are
able to engage your system too
and you get everything hundred percent
correct
so that's the kind of learning that's
that we see in humans
sometimes so sometimes people are not
able to pick up the rule
and then they will follow the monkey
path so
the their learning performance follows
pretty much the monkeys
but once if they get the rule then it's
just instantaneous
and and you you said that this system
too is quite slow for thinking
but fast for learning yeah system two
requires you to
think a while like when when you get a
card you
you need to match the what you see
with your rule and it's like a
deliberate thought process that takes a
little while
so it's not instantaneous but actually
once you get the rule you will also
start
engaging your system one pretty quickly
so that
the system two can train system one to
respond really quickly but system two
thinking inherently is slow that's why
daniel kahneman
in his book na i mean it was it was
titled
thinking fast and slow so fast
referring to system one and slow
referring to system two
but when it comes to speed of learning
it's actually reversed
so system two requires big data it's
always slow to learn
but system two can be really data
efficient do you think that
there is a dichotomy in thinking in
humans
because we had a wonderful discussion
last week and as an aside but we had a
comment on our youtube channel that
daniel kahneman apparently now regrets
some of the things he said and thinking
fast
and slow a lot of the experiments
weren't reproducible and they were
poorly designed and so on
but i i think it serves as a wonderful
analogy architecturally if nothing else
but last week we were having a
fascinating discussion where
we were being quite cynical and we
thought well if if system two is about
taking shortcuts
then when that new piece of knowledge or
skill has been consolidated does it just
become
system one well i would say that the
there is uh like under the hood
there is a clear difference about how
system one
works compared to system two it's i mean
if if you really start digging into it
nothing is black and white so
it's i wouldn't say that there's
clear and definitely there is no clear
anatomical separation between system one
and system two so it's rather two
different modes
of thinking but what really sets
system two apart from system one
if you think of algorithmically i guess
in this
this panel we are allowed to talk
algorithms right
so system two has an
internal model of the world and it's
running internal simulations
of that world and this is
this is a function that system one just
skips
it just jumps into conclusions much like
if you think of
ordinary deep neural network
inputs and then computation layer by
layer and then you have the output
computation is instantaneous more or
less
but there isn't thinking
behind it whereas when we build system 2
ai that's that means to me
that we are building ai that's actually
running
some internal modeling
of the world running simulations
so i think there is the clear
distinction between what system one
and system two can do i think there is a
meaningful
distinction also like algorithm wise
the world is never black and white so
there are there are
differences but if you for instance have
a reinforcement learning system
then i think model three and model based
there there is a difference and clearly
with with this definition of that i just
gave
model base would be system two because
it has an internal model
it's running some simulations and it's
basing it's planning
on on that the decisions are based on
on running internal simulations but
if you build a complete system you also
want to include
policy network which is initializing the
plans or
sometimes getting getting the
decisions right away and that's system
one and you want to combine those two
what do you think of joshua benjo's
sort of approach that system two
knowledge is whatever you can verbalize
how do you how do you think of that
because that kind of
was a bit controversial in our
conversation last
last week well i think
if you want to measure what system one
and system two in humans
asking up to verbalize is clearly an
a simple way to check that so it's very
practical
uh way to check i don't think that it's
a good
definition of what the distinction
between system one and system two but
it's certainly a practical way of
probing it
because they're all they're all sort of
uh a little bit different from each
other there's this
okay can i verbalize it then there is
the the aspect of does it run sort of
internal simulations because not even
though
let's say alphago is running internal
internal simulations
you can't really make a verbalization
out of it
right it simply it simply goes down the
monte carlo
tree search more often it can't
necessarily tell you
why because this is guided by the the
system one thinking and so on so i think
i think it is yeah there's these
multiple aspects of things and as you
say nothing is
nothing is black and white so yeah i
think what what makes it
a little bit confusing maybe is that as
you said like
al alpha go or alpha zero
it doesn't have also the policy which is
guiding
this planning but i would say that it
definitely has system two
in that it's explicitly selecting
the the decisions that are predicted to
yield the best outcome
based on that simulator and in in the
case of
alpha zero the the simulator is
handcrafted
we already know the games of the rules
of games
so we can just handcraft those
simulators and all
all chess engines are basically
running this kind of system to ai
they're not
learning necessarily anything and they
don't necessarily have
uh system one but i mean oh that could
be handcrafted too
but i i think that's for instance we we
can
say that in alpha alpha zero under my
definition the policy part
would be system one thinking but the
running the simulations that would be
the system two part
and it doesn't yeah so if we know the
algorithm then we can make this
distinction but
if you if you are asking a human or a
monkey then it's
we don't know exactly the algorithm and
we can't probe that directly
so if if we if we stay
with this definition of running internal
simulation
then of course the the immediate
question is
where does the simulator come from right
i think that's
that's like the the big part because in
let's say
classic ai you would rely on
the fact that you know the simulator
like alphago but also
you know the classic whatever a star
search algorithms expert systems whatnot
you know the simulator and so
i mean there is there is this question
where does the simulator come from
is it learned jointly or maybe in humans
you could argue
a lot of the simulators are built into
by evolution
right so it's it's sort of uh you have
a physics simulator inside of you from
birth
just given to you by that outer process
so
we can we can imagine so many levels it
can be completely handcrafted
it can be like meta-learned as in
there's an outer process that learns the
simulator and there's an inner process
learning or it can be jointly learned
with you acting in the world basically
you make a model
of the world what is what is sort of the
what is the most
interesting thing you think in this
space
well i think that's the interesting bit
is is learning the world model from
from data and you said for instance
humans come
in built with a lot of physics knowledge
i actually
think that there is a lot of
developmental psychology
pointing to the direction that no
actually we need to learn
physics that we are quite prepared to
live in which whichever physical reality
when we are born
we we learn all kinds of things even
starting from object constancy
from from experience but it's it's
something that you're not
hardwired with but you you learn that
very quickly you don't need to have
years and years of experience but you
can learn physics from data pretty
quickly and efficiently i think it's
interesting that some things do
seem to be baked into us as evolutionary
priors and some things we do
learn later you gave the example of
object permanence
i think monkeys actually learn object
permanence much quicker than humans do
and i'm interested in system two in
terms of learning games i think there
was a paper in iclear
a year or two ago and it was asking the
question why do humans
learn how to beat games so much faster
we're so much more
sample efficient and it's exactly as
yannick was saying we
understand gravity they did an
experiment where they took away some of
the textures in the atari games because
we know what a ladder means
we know what a platform means actually
if you turn the thing upside down so
gravity doesn't make sense anymore
if you remove enough priors that humans
have then
we are not much better than the
algorithm at that point
and what's your opinion on alphago i
think the way it's been branded
in the media is that in the olden days
it was
brute force searching in chess in
deep blue we were just brute force
searching this tree
and of with alphago it was supposedly
completely different we now have
this this policy i think in alphago they
combined the value
and the policy network into one but
i think if you just follow the policy
from this network the performance isn't
that good it's still doing this monte
carlo research it's not really that
different
in some sense to what came before yeah i
think
it's there's a very long tradition
actually and that's i think
do you know these samuel as checkers
it's i think it's from 50s
or something and in that that was
already combining
planning with learning
at least the value functions and so on
so i think there is actually quite long
tradition
in in combining some something like data
data-driven learning with with planning
and that didn't learn and didn't need to
learn the rules of the game but so
didn't
alpha alphago alpha zero so that that
was inbuilt
so in many ways i think the
the the seas have been there for
for a long time but obviously alpha zero
and alpha goal
at first it was a huge undertaking in
like really really building
building this system that that can
actually do that with all the
compute that that deep mind had at
this disposal so that
wasn't something that ordinary grad
student could have done
simply because they would have lacked
the compute
a friend and colleague of mine actually
predicted a year before
that we are at the brink of um
this revolution that is going to happen
soon he didn't know about
any of the work that deepmind was doing
but based on the
on the papers that that that had been
there already that were being published
he predicted that
we are going to make this breakthrough
like human level
go in yeah in about a year and then
that was a year before last week we were
having a fascinating discussion
it was a it was a trichotomous
discussion we were talking about
consciousness and we were talking about
intelligence and we were talking about
machine learning
and at the at the intro of that episode
we played some clips from christoph koch
and he was saying that
consciousness is just experience
and francois chile says the same thing
he says that consciousness is a
distraction
evolution is very intelligent but it's
not conscious
and conscious is according to francois
chile just about emotions it's not
something we should be
particularly interested in unless we
have an anthropocentric
view of intelligence but on intelligence
chalet says that it's all about
generalization difficulty kind of
divided by the priors in terms of
knowledge
and skills and in that setting some of
these reinforcement learning algorithms
are not intelligent
but the way you're framing it is they
are exceptional in some circumstances
for example they do planning
they can do things that we haven't been
able to do before and you're making an
argument that they were heading towards
a phase
change in intelligence so how do you
wrestle with these
aspects well about consciousness first
of all i
i think that consciousness is what the
brain does
so that's my personal view view of that
so it's uh
when we built this this more
more and more intelligent ai systems i
think we are building
into them things like the ability to
stimulate the world and also
ability to guide their own
planning guide their own thinking and
i think that at some point these systems
will be conscious
in the same way as as we are but i think
the consciousness is is not the goal but
it's just
a very like that that's what the system
will do
when it's thinking eventually
so i think that now
a lot of a lot of ai and particularly
the
the machine learning related parts of
a i have been dominated by this system
one
thinking big data take a lot of data and
just
learn a very efficient mapping from
inputs to outputs and that's
it's very very useful technology and
without that
in humans like without system one
thinking we would be
completely handicapped we would we would
be thinking
constantly about just moving this joint
or that joint or
like we wouldn't get very far in life
so it's very important that you have
something like system one
but i think that the for the past
decade ai being dominated by deep
learning and zone was
a bit imbalanced in that system two
a i wasn't really making a dent
the good old-fashioned ai on the other
hand in
you might argue that that was all about
system two ai
it was all about planning and reasoning
and now putting those things things
together i think will be
tremendously valuable and it's it's
going to be
yeah i i think this this decade will be
about actually putting those things
together
and i think that as an end result we
will have something like conscious
machines
this is a bit of a segue but how does
one build a
company on this i think of ai like it's
cool i do it at university and
okay machine learning has some business
applications but then when i think of
level two ai i think of games and
and yeah go and and and you know all
these kind of
playful tasks how does one make money
with this
or how do you make money yeah that's a
good question
one answer would be like tell me
immediately when you find out
the other other thing is i was once in a
conference where jeff hinton was talking
about
his his research and he said that
in his mind like and he was talking
about a lot of
neuroscientists saying that this stuff
that you've built
has nothing to do with brain
hinton said that thing about brain he
thinks one of the most important
features about the brain is
that it works it can actually solve
real-world problems and i think that's
that's a very
good way towards like really advanced ai
build something that solves real world
problems
now if you pick the wrong sort of
problem
you might end up in the wrong
ecological niche and you might be
developing stuff
which doesn't actually then in the long
run
leads to advanced ai and if
if we look at animal evolution we can
see many many examples of this so
there were many branches of animals
which
developed very very clever things and
clever brains that that achieved many
things
but didn't really get further than that
and definitely didn't go all the way to
moon
so we we have been in curiosity we have
been trying to find
the kinds of uh problems that are worth
solving
and whose solutions will take us step by
step
a little bit closer to to building real
ai and i'm not saying that's easy
we when we started the company we we had
some very good
investors who who believed in this track
and we we spent a few years
just developing the algorithms
and figuring out what what we can do
better than than anybody else and then
then you are at starting point where
which is even before normal companies
that which is like okay now we
we have some cool technology we know
what it can do we know it's better
now let's try to make business out of it
so that might be
might be the starting point of of many
startups and then
then you start looking for the the right
application and now
now we have figured it out now we know
what we can do like where
where this tech we've developed is is
much better than anything else
but we've spent like four and a half
years already
in the company life and now we are ready
to go to market with a product
so i i guess you need to have also
patient investors if you if you want to
do it this way and
it wouldn't have been possible if not
for my previous company
so the investors already knew knew me
and
knew that the stuff that we are building
has great potential
so they they've been patient it seems
crazy
imagine going to an investor and say
please give me money for
four and a half years and uh after four
and a half years we might start looking
for
for a problem so if you can say what
what is the the problem that you now
found
just as a quick aside on that yannick if
the reward comes after four years you
need to do some reward shaping
sure you need to tell the investors
soon soon no soon very soon
developed this system two ai ai which
is running its internal simulation so so
much like
alpha zero actually except that
if you go to real world and many
problems
don't have a simple nice
game environment type place where you
it's easy to just type in the rules of
the game
most real world problems are such that
you don't actually know what the rules
are
and what we've developed is is this
system two ai
that can learn the rules of the game and
then solve
solve the game so this is this is
something that actually
has a long tradition in control
engineering
so control theories is all about
optimal control you you assume
some kind of system model and then you
solve for it
so now we are just cross-breeding
good old-fashioned control engineering
with modern ai so we can use deep neural
networks to learn
process models and then we can apply
them across
industries so controlling complex
high-dimensional non-linear
processes with delays and change
and all of all of those things that you
you encounter in the real world
that's what we do yeah i think this is
really interesting because
so many of the reinforcement learning
papers that that we look at
are focused in the artificial world
they're focused
on computer games which are completely
observable
the atari system are using deep q
networks from deepmind
that was a model three method which
meant it was learning the policy by
interacting directly with the system and
in the real world you don't necessarily
have that luxury of being able to
interact with with the real world and
this is when we start getting into model
based machine learning where we
build a model of our environment which
means we can learn
inside our virtual world without having
to interact with the real world
and it seems to open up all sorts of
interesting possibilities because we can
explore
this virtual world as well and yannick
did a wonderful
video about the the curiosity paper um
recently
so this model-based reinforcement
learning is is squarely where where you
folks are pitched
is that correct that's correct and tim
you mentioned that
model-based approaches allow you to
learn
inside your internal simulation but
i think that actually at least as
important
if not even more is the ability to solve
new situations that you didn't
anticipate
before so if you think for instance
what uh what makes alpha alpha zero
so so good is not just the policy that
it learned in the end
but it's the ability to actually apply
planning for that
game position that you now have
from in front of you so
a lot of model based reinforcement
learning which is like using these
internal models
has been focused on using those models
for
generating experience inside
which is then distilled into a policy
network
but i think that everybody would
like to do proper planning like
online planning plan for
plan the best actions for this situation
that you have
in front of you so that's that's the
kind of thing that we
we've been developing proper model based
ai
so you describe planning as an
adversarial attack on the model
could you tell me a little more about
like this idea of that like the
how the model kind of compounds its
errors as it predicts into the future
and then kind of the
open loop versus closed loop differences
with these world models
yeah so the reason why planning has been
so difficult
to to tame is that if you have
any weaknesses in your model
the planning process will immediately
exploit those
because planning is trying to find
something
completely different something new some
new way
of doing things and if you're not
careful
then and and with with models that have
learned from data
it's it's clear that the model will not
be
accurate outside of the training
manifold
and that's that's clear that's just life
it's it's unavoidable it's not possible
to know something where you don't
have any experience so
what's what this planning is essentially
doing it's
it's the same thing as what
what you would like it's a recipe for
adversarial
attack so let's take an example of a
classifier
we i i guess everybody's heard about
these examples where
you pick a perfectly good classifier
which can classify
almost any images that are thrown at it
but then when you start generating
an image and you say there's this panda
gibbon classic example so you you take
an image of panda
and then the network correctly
classifies it as such
but then you ask okay how should i
change this
inputs so that it would look like a
gibbon
so you you reverse the network you use
it as a generator
and it produces complete gibberish
this is what happens also if you if you
pick
neural network models that are able to
predict
what will happen if in this process if i
do
if i apply these controls so the
controls are inputs
to the predictive model and the outcome
is something that then you want to
optimize
now when you try to work your way
backwards from your desired
goals to inputs you are generating
and the control but actually what
happens is that you are generating an
adversarial example
if you're not careful so
that's that's been a problem that's uh
it's it's not just me thinking that
that's
that's a problem there was a awesome
talk
in last year's iclear by martha
lillycrap
so i think tim said that's that's that's
the
problem that they had stumbled upon
in in deep mind and that's that's
something that we started working on
more than three years ago and we managed
to solve it
i'd say because we had this background
in
in unsupervised learning helsinki has
always been
very strong in unsupervised learning due
to the
pioneering work of my first boss devo
cohonin
he he invented these self self-organized
organizing maps and
i was working on all kinds of
unsupervised learning things when i
i started as a researcher and
unsupervised learning with deep neural
networks has been
at the heart of solving this problem
because when you generate
uh your controls or when you're
generating your pandas and gibbons
you need to be aware of your
input distribution and that's that's
really the realm of
unsupervised learning trying to
understand your input distributions
properly
one of the things though is i think cnns
for example are really good
at encoding the system one
representations of the visual
environment
reinforcement learning seems to struggle
with the sparse rewards
and it's very very difficult to train
these systems
and i don't think the problem is having
good representations for the system
state
we encode so much prior information into
these architectures
like the the open ai dota 5
system they had loads of reward shaping
if you pick up a bit of gold you get a
point if you do this you get a point and
one thing that concerns me is we're
supposed to be moving away from expert
systems
what we want is to have systems that
genuinely learn from data
but i think people are often surprised
by the amount of
prior knowledge and skills that we are
imputing into these systems
yeah then again i think that these deep
neural networks they really have
made made a breakthrough in in how
little domain knowledge we actually need
to develop efficient and functioning
systems so maybe not in in these
dota game examples but like
when when people started
applying to competitions machine vision
or
speech recognition or drug development
or whatever these competitions
they weren't experts in in those domains
they were experts in building these deep
neural networks
and then they started winning winning
the competitions of course
always when you when you're single in
in one particular application domain
uh use i mean it's it's possible to
start
developing attend better models by
combining
very flexible learning systems with
a lot of domain specific knowledge
but i i think that's the
initial solution provided but just by
just
taking pretty much vanilla lstm networks
applying that to whatever industrial
processes
that's worked surprisingly well so
i guess this is not good advertisement
for
our customers but really we really are
not experts in process control
i can tell you about these deep neural
networks they are great
at extracting the relevant knowledge we
need to understand a little bit
about the processes for sure but
yeah i think more or less
we can just be content with predicting
the future observations and be done with
that
so i i want to go back a little bit
because
to to just what what what your company
or a company like yours
would do and i i think so maybe i
came up with sort of an example that you
could solve and maybe you can say if
that's correct or not so if you think of
for example a sewage treatment plant
right you have like whatever water
coming in from all kind of places you
need to guide it through various
basins there's like a biological
component where you use bacteria to
clean it in this tank and so on then
this can you know
drop away and then you have an outage
here and
and there you have all these kinds of
delays so and and you need to kind of
set all these valves such that the water
flows and
it needs to be clean and and is this the
kind of systems you're talking about
like i i'm having a bit of a hard time
imagining exactly like what you do is
this the sort of things that you would
tackle with your um ai are you sure that
we didn't discuss about this
uh no are you doing this today
today i had a call with some uh control
experts in
sewage systems
spot on okay yeah okay so this
i mean this gives me a better idea
because um yeah yeah that's exactly it
like if you think of those kinds of
processes they are
they are really difficult to
properly model using
physical or like actually you need
physical and
chemical and biological knowledge like
really modeling it properly is uh
well i i guess it's really impossible
but we can collect data from the system
humans are operating those systems every
day
and humans learn to understand
roughly okay if i turn this valve then
that liquid turns
brownish and that's good because then
down the line it's clean water
so humans learn to make these these
kinds of
predictions and causal models and then
they are able to apply
these models when something breaks for
instance
suddenly okay let's take an example
which everybody is hopefully
no nobody is familiar with but suppose
that we are flying an airplane
and suddenly an engine one one engine
shut off shuts off
the the dynamics of of the airplane
change
quite immediately and you you'd hope
that the
pilot is able to learn the new dynamics
and figure out a way how to fly the
plane
and this is this is this kind of stuff
is actually
something that also happens in industry
components break and you still need to
clean that water
could we linger on yannick's example
because i think this is very instructive
i mean when you read papers about model
based reinforcement learning they might
be talking about
playing doom or quake and you might make
a model which will take in the pixels of
your current scene
and it would learn well this person
pressed the forward button and this was
the next frame so
you're kind of learning you know given
given this
scene and this action what's what's the
observation likely to be
if i did that in this case that yannick
just sketched out
it seems to be a little bit more
heterogeneous so would you need multiple
models for the different aspects of the
system
so we've been happy with just having
on one big model if you have for
instance different types of sensors then
you might want to have
different pre-processing stages so if if
they are not just
thermometers and pressure sensors and
flow sensors and that kind of like
one-dimensional signal sensors
if you also have cameras for instance
then you don't want to put those
all in this like you don't want to treat
them the same way but then you'd apply
you know convolutional networks for for
that
particular sensory input but
by and large right i'd say yeah i mean
you just throw it
all into the same same big deep neural
network and it
works great so that's that's the promise
of learning right
so do you like have a separate cnn for
the camera data and then like
you know maybe some kind of lcm for the
1d and like kind of fuse in these
features
later on or is it like but i i can tell
you
that we haven't been working on on
camera data with
with these these problems and and
frankly i don't think that's
it's very sensible to apply
reinforcement learning for
vision problems it's
so much more sensible to just apply good
old-fashioned machine vision
and then apply reinforcement learning on
on the reasonable feature representation
oh i'm surprised to hear you say that
because as i was saying before i think
that
things like cnns are really really good
at
finding good features from even pixels
you can you can learn the state of an
atari game
but one thing i did want to understand
is i'm trying to
place where your differentiated
um capability is and i i don't
completely understand because i know
there's a lot of work around
this curiosity paper for example that's
all about
every single action you take you kind of
you see
how how much of a surprise was it how
predictable was it and you can
use something like that to encourage
exploration of you know parts of the
environment that you don't know much
about so so that that's about
exploration
but when i've been reading some of the
materials on your website it seems to be
more around
uh regularization to perform well
um outside of the manifold or outside of
your training domain or
is it is it more that or is there an
exploration element to it as well
there is an exploration element
unfortunately that's
still unpublished work so can't talk
much
about it but hey the name of the company
is curious hey
so you you'd expect us to have some
something on expiration too and yeah
the the thing that we have managed to
crack
really properly is combining deep neural
networks for learning
or or other data-driven models
for learning the system dynamics and
couple that with
very efficient optimization techniques
and the the problem that people have
struggled with
in trying to do this is that is this
adversarial
planning attack problem that planning
actually exposes
any and all of the weaknesses that the
model will have
and what we've done is we've we've been
able to regularize
the the planning process such that
the planning will will stay within
the familiar within
familiar manifold or to with to the
network so
it's actually actually it's kind of
anti-curiosity
that that makes this thing thing work so
yeah i know there's some irony to that
but yeah so we've developed this
anti-curiosity which actually makes it
possible to develop proper
system two model-based reinforcement
learning and
add proper curiosity on top of that
so just just really quickly i'm just
reading a bit from your paper
because the way you frame it up in and
hari is a nips published
in europe's published author which is
we're so excited to have him on the show
and you're saying that in traditional
model based reinforcement learning
planning is done by computing the
expected result of a sequence of future
actions using an explicit model of the
environment
and it's fairly well assumed in the rl
community that
these planning methods improve the
sample efficiency problem
which is which is a huge issue so how do
you go on to
address this planning issue in your
architecture
so the the key problem in
in using planning with these
learned networks is that the planning
process
shoots off immediately out of the
familiar familiar manifold
and then then the network can give
complete rubbish
there have been other solutions so some
some people have
tackled this problem by plugging
in proper bayesian
uncertainty so it's it's really down to
not a literary but epistemic uncertainty
so it's the epistemic uncertainty that
that kills this this planning and
rather than than build this complicated
base in
machinery and i'm i'm basing that's hard
so i think beyond is great but
we don't want to implement bayesian
stuff at the
microscopic level of these networks
so if you think like in in basin terms
your epistemic uncertainty is is found
when you go outside of your training
domain
so when when the probability of your
input
starts being small compared to
what what your training data would
suggest
and we we found a way
to to train a neural network adenosine
autoencoder to effectively figure out
what the training distribution is
and give the gradients that point
uphill in this
probability distribution of the training
training data
and that's that that gradient is
is the key to like it's the antidote
against this adversarial planning attack
so during planning every planning step
where you are optimizing your objective
function
it gives goes upwards here in
the target target objective
function but then it goes downhill
the probability of your input data
so we remedy that by pushing it back
back up then maybe the
the objective will also go down a little
bit but
that's okay because it's better to be
realistic
about your objective function rather
than
if if objective function goes up and
probability goes down
then the objective is what the network
thinks
is very high high objective is actually
not
so we we we keep
pushing the probability of input up so
as to keep
the epistemic uncertainty of this model
as low as possible and if you do the
maths you can see that
there there is a term that we need there
which is the
gradient of log probability of your
input
this input trajectory and
it turns out that using auto encoders
very naturally
output this this kind of value this is
something that we
we actually proved thoroughly
there is i think we have an archive
paper
about that so we we didn't publish this
in any any conference or anything
it's it's a thing that has been known to
hold approximately
already before but we we showed the
exact relation
so these denoising autoencoders are
actually giving the
gradient of log probability of of the
input distribution
so actually we can i mean we haven't
properly shouted out the paper it's
called regularizing trajectory
optimization with
denoising auto encoders so for anyone
you know who wants to check that out
so is it is it fair to if i had to
describe the paper on a high level
is it fair to say that if i'm planning
with a model that i also learn
then i run into i run into this danger
of
of basically planning where my model
doesn't really know
stuff yet and if i'm not a bayesian as
you say then i can't
i sort of can't know that my model
doesn't know
stuff now what other other papers try to
do
is kind of like guess guess
that i don't know stuff or they try to
actually push the model
or the exploration towards that space
where
i don't know where my model doesn't know
things and therefore they say okay
in future iterations i you know if i
push
if i go there in future iterations i
will know what's happening there
but you you go a different way you
basically say that
i know my planning will fail once i go
to a place where my model doesn't know
so i make sure that my planning process
actually only goes to where my model
is where i know my model is good is that
kind of
does this describe it and does that
describe the relevance yeah it does
thing
yeah and to be to be fair there have
been many many other
proposals in this direction for instance
gilco
is is implicitly at least doing that by
using gaussian processes as the
underlying model
and they are really really good at
modeling the epistemic uncertainty
like it's inbuilt
in in this model structure however they
are
pretty cumbersome like you you wouldn't
like to apply this kind of
gaussian process when you have an say
oil refinery with
thousands of measurements and hundreds
of control variables
you just wouldn't like to apply a
gaussian process for that
and these deep neural networks they are
great they can learn these kinds of very
complex processes
so the path we took was to
rather than try to somehow change the
deep neural network so that
it would manage this epistemic
uncertainty
we we built the kind of safety net
around it so so it's keeping this
planning process safe
but yeah you're correct and there have
been this this kind of regularization
which is
trying to be conscious of
of the input distribution that it has
been
used even in in control theory it's just
that the
the models have been far simpler so
something like for instance mixture of
gaussians model for
for the input distribution and now if
you have
a very complex process model
a deep neural network lstm with multiple
layers and whatnot
it's like you have this lamborghini you
have great
machine under you and then if you
are forced to use input distribution
model like mixture of gaussians
it's like okay then we have this five
kilometers per hour speed limit
so what was the purpose of buying the
lamborghini in the first place
so rather what we had we are doing is we
are
using another deep neural network which
understands the input distribution
and there could have been other
alternatives like for instance
variational autoencoders or
or something like that but the trouble
is
that if you if your network outputs
a probability of the input and then you
are optimizing it
through gradients or some other very
efficient optimization method
then the optimization process
is bound to find weaknesses joint
weaknesses
in your predictive model and then this
distribution model
we tried it it failed so another
very popular alternative is to use an
ensemble of models
to model the epistemic uncertainty so
the idea is that once you have multiple
different models
then when you go outside
of your training distribution then the
models start disagreeing
and you can you can measure the
epistemic uncertainty with an ensemble
we've tested that and it just
breaks immediately if you apply
efficient planning
techniques like gradient-based planning
if the planning
itself is a little bit inefficient then
you can get away with that but
i think it's very dangerous
to rely on using imperfect
optimization techniques to do
model-based reinforcement learning so
i'd rather fix
the root cause of the problem and then
use the most efficient
optimization technique there is so with
with these with these ensembles
is it that if i have a really efficient
planner
it will just find the point where all
the ensembles this
like are wrong but in the same way
they're basically saying all they're
saying the same thing so you say well
this is really sure
bet but you're basically just
adversarial exampling
all of them at the same time and as long
as you have a low dimensional
control space where you you don't have
that many variables to optimize
that might be fine but when you start
having tens or hundreds of
control variables to optimize at the
same time you're doomed
yeah could you define just for the
benefit of any
any listeners that don't know what it
means because i think it has quite a
specific definition epistemic
uncertainty
oh yeah sorry i used electric and
epistemic as if that would be known to
everybody so platoric refers to
the kind of uncertainty that you have in
throwing dyes for instance like even
though we know
the dynamics of these dyes pretty well
every time i throw dice
i i i get a different
answer so aaliyah
this is the latin what's that in english
i has been thrown or ties has been cast
or something like that
yeah i had a look on wikipedia and it
said some
sometimes a measurement may not be
accurate because the model neglects
certain effects or because particular
data has been deliberately
hidden so an example of this they quote
is the drag
yeah quantum physics pretty much
guarantees that you are going to have
alleratoric uncertainty in
anything that you you do so it has to be
really a game environment
in order for you not to have alatoric
uncertainty but the
the moment you hit physics you will hit
a lottery uncertainty
so quantum physics is all about electric
uncertainty for instance
you you do the same experiment million
times and every time you get slightly
different
different answer so yeah that's
that's electric and this is easy type of
uncertainty because you can basically
learn that from data training data you
can you can
reliably train networks that output
probabilities
rather than just crisp values
that's because the network will will see
multiple different outcomes for the same
input and
it will learn to output a distribution
properly
but epistemic uncertainty is when
the model doesn't know yet typically
that's because we haven't seen
these kinds of things yet or maybe we've
seen something like that but
while waiting the the world went
unchanged
and this is this is very typical in
inferences industrial processes
yes we have years and years of data
but these processes keep changing all
the time
without telling us unfortunately so
by the time that you you get your
uh number process and you are supposed
to make the decision your training data
is already
invalid so that's epistemic uncertainty
something which we do not know
yet when typically happens when you go
outside
your your training data but it can also
be that
the training data is there but the model
just went unchanged
i'm interested in your process as a
company to use the annex example again
what would success look like and what
would the process be
for you to start to develop these models
and put them together and when google
and deepmind create models like this
they have huge teams and they have
vast amounts of compute and there is
still an element of it being a black r
and being trial and error and quite
experimental
what does your process look like so we
are packaging this
this model-based reinforcement learning
into a toolbox that
any control engineer would be able to
use
without understanding all the finesses
of
machine learning they are typically
experts of their
uh domain processes
so they they they understand the
measurements and controls and all of
that stuff and they are needed
in in these projects we are we are
packaging this model-based reinforcement
learning
into a toolbox which which these people
would be able to use they need to
understand the concept
of training data and training a model
and validating
the model but they wouldn't need to know
all about dropout and lstm
and you know all of these machine
learning
stuff that we we breathe
every day so that's that's how success
was would look like
i'm expertising model based
reinforcement learning so that
it's not cool anymore
you you mentioned at the very beginning
you mentioned something like
system two and and especially humans
learn rules very quickly right and once
you learn the rule behind something you
make this
great progress and what comes to mind to
me also from the more classical ai
is things like planning over over these
causal factor graphs and explainability
when you say you know the rules i
learned the rule and i have this causal
model
do you see do you see any role for these
types of things
in the system two ais or yeah absolutely
and now actually
we're touching a point which which
relates
also to using these simulators not just
for
control but also for
analysis i think when when we
encounter a new situation
that we haven't seen before we can apply
system 2 thinking in
analysis we can run simulation so my my
favorite example is sheryl colmes
arriving at the crime scene and seeing
scratching the sofa and lipstick in the
mirror and then
by some okay so running some internal
simulations obviously
sherlock uh declares that was a ballet
dancer
i don't know how he does it but somehow
he
arrives at a wonderful conclusion so
he's
he's built this whole simulation of the
whole setup
in his head and this this kind of
way of analyzing the world is something
that
system 2 ai is also capable of doing and
i mean that's that's something that
curious ai has been working on we we
were
working on document automation using
generative modeling like you know
simulating
where finding an explanation of where
did these documents
come from like why why are these numbers
like we see them and so on
that's something that we've now put on
hold for a while like now we are
fully focused on model-based
reinforcement learning and
industrial processes but definitely
having a good causal model that can
also explain the data that we see
and base its predictions
on these kinds of analyses that's
something that
i i clearly see in the future
for the time being we are using system
one
uh black box modeling for developing
this
predictive model but it's als it would
be possible to also
apply system 2 ai in building the
predictive model
itself you would add another layer of
explainability
to the system but
what we've seen is that actually people
are pretty happy
communicating with this this
model based reinforcement learning ai
system
in terms of predictions so they are
happy
seeing that the model thinks we should
do this
because it leads to those consequences
so yeah
we can visualize the predictions of the
model and the system doesn't want to do
this other thing because it's predicting
those
outcomes so it's a very intuitive way
of debugging the system and
understanding what the system is
thinking
and you don't need to know why
the system is making these predictions
we don't oftentimes probe other people's
understanding here sometimes we do and
our ai wouldn't be able to do that right
now
maybe sometimes in the future this is a
key philosophical question
the what versus the why with humans we
don't ask the why
we don't ask airplane pilots why they
know what they do
and yoshiya bengio made the assertion
that some knowledge is not verbalizable
i really like that concept especially
when you talk about these black box
system one models
i agree with you that when we have this
higher level of thinking this system too
we can place a structure around
why we are doing things but again in
bengio's talk
he was talking about creating these high
level factor graphs
but it doesn't seem possible to be able
to learn these factor graphs
as the case has been for many years we
can build
models ourselves which allow us to
reason
and perform a higher level of
introspection and
verbalization but we don't seem to be
able to learn this higher level of
thinking
i think that there is something still
some some work still to be done
in neurosymbolic uh systems
so systems which are able to do symbolic
simple manipulation with neural
architectures our brain clearly does it
we have a neural network inside and we
can
pretty certainly do symbolic simple
manipulation
so when when doing abstract mathematics
for instance we are clearly manipulating
symbols
now we've actually scratched
that problem from on the surface a
little bit
we were working on something like
unsupervised segmentation system so
really learning objects representations
from pixels and our collaborator
allows graph continued that work like
modeling in the interactions between
these objects
and so on curious a i dropped that
kind of research for now so that's
another thing that we have put on hold
because we've we figured that in
in actual reality when you go and solve
real world problems
that's not really the bottleneck most
most of the time
humans are really efficient at defining
the
object structure or the symbolic
structure of the problem
and we we can do that very efficiently
and we can
apply these black box learning learning
systems
efficiently in in other other syst other
things
so like predicting the signals and
and so on which don't really require all
that much
symbolic thinking but i'm i'm quite sure
that we this is something that we will
still revisit
at some point and i'm i'm
certain that there there is a way to and
i i think that we
even know um a good starting point like
where to go how to start building these
neurosymbolic
uh models which are not only able to
predict the individual signals and
and so on but which are also able to
learn to represent
an in an unsupervised manner learn to
represent the world
in terms of objects and their
interactions
that's a really really uh deep topic
a big topic in and of itself which
a company that actually needs to make
something
something workable for their their
customers and cannot afford to do now
but one day once we've uh cracked the
all the industrial control problems in
the world
i'm sure that we will have some
resources
dedicated to that problem too
it's quite a a different plan for
the it seems it seems like maybe correct
me if i'm wrong but it seems like
there is this way what you're doing in
that you say
you know there's these industrial
control problems and once we know we
figure out how to
basically do this uh system two latent
planning
and we figure out how to solve this
problem of not planning where we don't
know we'll be able to solve these
and there's this entire other game
that maybe someone like deepmind is
playing where they say
we might just be able to solve go and
that will make so much pr
that people will throw money at us for
basically just because we've we we're so
good
because we basically we have such good
people right
and there seems a bit of a it seems
different trajectories
i'm sure there are a lot of people right
now listening or watching that
wonder kind of if i want to go into ai
with business like as a business person
if i want to start my company or join a
startup or somewhat
do you have any sort of insider
recommendation
of what's what's sort of the
the smartest way to go about if you want
to
because there's a lot of space still for
ai startups right
and what's the smartest way to go about
doing something like this well i think
that there are many smart ways
of doing it so there's not just one one
model which fits all but
i think first of all you need to decide
whether you you want to build
a company to be an acquisition target
rather than build a company which stands
on its own
for instance curious ai we founded a
company which
is doing its own business and it's not
primarily an acquisition target
so but there i know other companies that
have been quite successful
in in both this way of working
and so also companies that have just
decided okay we'll
make a lot of noise about ourselves and
then some big company will
buy us it's a i mean if if you want that
then
that that's fine that's not something
that's and that that
wasn't the kind of company that i wanted
to build because
i think we we really accurate we
really do have a plan of how to build
really really advanced like
human style ai if not human level
immediately at least human style
ai really advanced ai and i think that
rather than trying to get us ourselves
into
as a research department of a bigger
company it makes sense to really
really build business out of this first
and that's that's what we
did if you want to build a business type
ai companies some ai company that really
has its own business i think for most
ai startups the the why strategy is to
focus on a particular vertical
figure out a problem and then solve that
no matter what
ai or not just solve that particular
problem
and that that makes sense for most
companies it's it's a little bit like if
you
are a gaming game company you you want
to build a cool game
there are only so many companies that
can build game engines
for other game companies to to use
now curious ai is is this kind of
game engine type company we built
the some fundamentally new ai
for which we then then need to figure
out what is the
best business for that and that's a long
path
that i wouldn't recommend to to try at
home
or at business so this this is the
the hard way that's the path we chose
and we
we were lucky enough to have visionary
enough
investors who who were willing to back
this up and now we are here like now we
can show
that hey cool model-based reinforcement
learning that
actually works in the real world i'm
solving
solving important problems for real
companies
we we are tackling the core processes
of big companies those like
if we can get 10 percent improvement in
those core processes
that's a lot of money for these these
companies so we've definitely found
ourselves
a really really good good market
it only took us four years and without
really patient investors we would have
run out of money
long long long time ago
kudos to you for doing so that so many
people
are really excited about getting into
the world of reinforcement learning and
machine learning
and you are being a trailblazer you're
making this work
i discovered you folks on on linkedin
and you're having a huge impact
already so kudos to you
well thank you yeah i think that most of
the impact is still to be made
though can i just one quick question oh
sorry what do you think like how much is
the
inference so i read the paper about
closed loop where you
simulate whole entire trajectories then
take one step and then
plan again and then you have the infant
speed so i'm just curious about like
real world application of these
reinforced learning models
how much is the inference time through
these neural networks like a bottleneck
and applying this
well nowadays it's not a bottleneck at
all and this
this so-called reseeding horizon
planning has been a bread and butter of
control engineering for for decades
so it's been running out there in
industrial process
processes and production for decades
already
and now we have so much more
compute at our disposal than
you know those pioneers way back
that it's it's a non-trivial amount of
compute
so even though daniel kahneman
talks about system two as the
slow thinking you take modern computers
and is blazingly fast
thinking i've been able to apply that
for
controlling autonomous vehicles in real
time and
stuff like that so it's it's not really
a problem at all
and in these industrial processes they
are
you know huge processes with so much
inertia
in them like really physical inertia
that they
the responses there can take hours
we could do hundreds of milliseconds
easily
even milliseconds with with modern
computers
so this is just non-trivial amount of
computing
so do you find any value in things sorry
sorry i meant to say trivial amount of
compute
so do you find value in things like
quantization or pruning or knowledge
distillation for compressing the models
or it's not even
it's not even a problem and don't even
bother with it there is value in
distillation we are
yeah that's that's that's something
that's that's helpful but
not maybe for the for
not only for compressing the models but
also for
improving generalization
so you do publish obviously this the
research that you do and it seems
to be you publish quite the some of the
core
components of of what you do at your
company right
do you do you also like how how far does
this openness go and where do you see
the true value of the company is it in
the code itself or do you
would you are you open sourcing the code
and say well no the actual value is in
us going there and actually doing the
thing where
what do you where is the balance between
like openness and
and and doing money like company secret
yeah i i mean company secrets is the
default mode for
operation in in any any business i guess
and the the antidote
against against that is the patenting
system
so companies like
say google they have their core business
and they they are pretty secretive about
that's that business but yeah they can
publish about
us ai is our core business
and if we just publish everything
without attenting
first then we would be out of business
sooner rather than later so we could
do a business out of it as long as we
stay
in the niches where big players wouldn't
be so interested but
for a company like us we are developing
new technology
and we we are patenting this new
technology
and that makes it possible for us to
publish
things patents up applications so i
think
i come from academia so i know what i
can
academic think about that ending and
it's it's
evil source of all evil
but that's not really the case like
without patenting
we wouldn't be able to publish anything
really could you contrast your position
on this versus a facebook or a google
for example i always used to make the
argument that
google could release their algorithms
because their value was the data
the face net triplet loss siamese
network yeah that's a cool architecture
but the best data set in the public
domain is
i think it's called labeled faces in the
world which has 14 000 faces in
google has a data set which has 26
million faces in
so that's where the value was but that
argument doesn't work anymore because
take the latest t5 natural language
processing
model from google they've given it away
they've given
the trained version that they're giving
it away presumably they're patenting
this as well i don't know if they are
but how is it different
so i think it's useful to keep in mind
that
google's product is not this
this kind of space recognition system
you are the product their business
is advertising search engines
if you think about what what google
did in the in the beginning like page
rank was a clear
improvement like it was very much better
technology than
than their competitors they didn't
really publish that immediately they
didn't
reveal all all their secrets about how
they are building their
search engine so that's what i mean that
the core business of google is still
search engines and
and this stuff is is a big part of what
google does
and they are not telling all their
secrets about that
part of business for sure
awesome well we are coming up to time
and i would just like to take this
opportunity hari just to say thank you
so much it's been an honor to talk with
you
i honestly think that you serve as an
inspiration for many of our viewers who
might one day build their own startup
around reinforcement learning and
machine learning
and i thoroughly recommend any potential
customers
who have control problems get in touch
with hari and curious ai
these folks are a wonderful startup
thank you team it has been such a
pleasure
and with such an expert expert
people like i know yannick how how you
did the trick about the switch
black magic
amazing brilliant